foreign
I'm here today as a guest on land that
was stolen from the Ute Cheyenne and
Arapahoe Nations
Lynn that many other tribal Nations
thought of as home before those
relationships were written over by
settler colonialism
so land acknowledgments like this have
become pretty commonplace at the
beginning of events at universities
sometimes in our email signatures
but I've always found them to be kind of
confusing like once you admit something
is stolen aren't you supposed to give it
back
so if there's anyone listening who has a
couple hundred spare Acres that you're
feeling guilty about just contact your
local tribal government we would be
happy to relieve you of that burden
that's probably not you right
maybe you've heard of this movement to
return land to indigenous people but
you're thinking I can barely afford rent
what is it I'm supposed to be giving
back
that's what I want to clarify today
because not only is getting land back in
indigenous hands in your best interests
and the best interest of the land itself
there's ways anyone can help make it
happen I'm a descendant of the turtle
Mountain band of Chippewa Indians which
is part of the anishinaabe nation of the
Great Lakes region home for me is also
the Pacific Northwest I grew up on
kalapuya and Malala territory and now
I'm a professor of indigenous studies at
CSU
my ancestors worked very hard to
navigate a complex and changing world
that was ravaged by settler colonialism
my grandma and both of her parents
survive the trauma and abuse of the
Indian boarding school system
the generation before them fought to
keep our tribe from being terminated by
the federal government
going even further back my six times
great grandfather's signature is on the
1863 Treaty of old Crossing
which forced the anishinabe to give up
11 million Acres of what's now Minnesota
in exchange for a little over four
hundred thousand dollars and a 640 acre
reservation
that works out to about five cents an
acre which has to be one of the worst
land deals
in U.S history
or maybe the best depending on who you
ask
this sort of thing happened all over the
U.S and Canada
the problem isn't just that settlers
showed up and took the land
it's how they've treated it ever since
that land we lost in Minnesota the
Enbridge line three pipeline goes right
through the middle of it
that freaking pipeline is responsible
for the largest Inland oil spill ever
recorded in the U.S
and now
they're trying to expand it
whether we're talking pipelines or some
other industry the colonial mindset has
been about extracting resources
mostly with the goal of making the rich
richer
but that's why landvac is not about
indigenous people trying to run a real
estate scam
we're doing this because the land itself
is in crisis
every indigenous culture is unique but
our shared philosophy is that we come
from the land and the land is what
sustains us and therefore we have a
responsibility to care for it
thank you
land back is about reasserting
indigenous relationships with the land
relationships that are based on tens of
thousands of years of hands-on
experience taking care of our homelands
if you've ever tried your hand at
farming or gardening you know that Land
Management takes more than just showing
up with good intentions
globally indigenous people are really
good at managing for biodiversity and
resilient ecosystems
that's because we've had generation upon
generation to test out what works and
what doesn't
there's tons of evidence and examples to
back this up one recent study showed
that indigenous people make up just five
percent of the global population but
we're managing nearly half the areas on
Earth that are protected for
conservation or still support intact
ecosystems
in the United States tribal Nations have
reintroduced endangered species even
when the government said it wouldn't
work
so in the Northwest where I grew up most
of the big Rivers have been damned which
makes it super hard for salmon to
survive and many runs have gone extinct
so back in the 90s the nimipu people
told the state of Idaho hey we'd like to
bring coho salmon back to the Snake
River
the state fish and wildlife guys were
like I don't think so
but the tribe did it anyway they got
eggs that one of the hatcheries was
gonna throw away incubated them and
basically snuck the fish back into the
river
and now they're doing so well that the
state has reopened the sport fishery and
the tribe is reintroducing Coho to a
bunch of other rivers
same thing with Buffalo back in the
1800s when the railroads were going in
and Native people were literally being
kicked off the land at gunpoint Buffalo
were nearly exterminated because they
thought that would make it easier to
subdue the tribes you depended on them
so get this most of the Buffalo that you
see today in zoos or Wildlife reserves
are actually descended from conservation
herds that native People Protected back
then
and now the blackfeet nation is bringing
free-ranging Buffalo back to their
Homeland in Montana
we're also pretty good at cleaning up
the ecological messes caused by
colonialism the town of Eureka
California was like okay we're ready to
give some land back we know it's
culturally a really important place to
you uh oh and by the way it's a super
fun site so it's hella polluted good
luck with that
and the Wyatt tribe said great we'll
take it and now they're in the process
of successfully remediating the site
they've removed tons of trash and
contaminated soil
they're working on erosion control and
wildlife habitat and making it a place
where they can hold ceremonies again
the land is better off in indigenous
hands because we treat the land like
it's a relative
even our youth know how this works so I
run a summer camp for Native kids where
we talk about indigenous science and how
we relate to the land so last summer
after the camp wraps up Henry's mom
calls me he's one of the campers he's
six
and she says he's had a falling out with
his best friend
they were playing outside and the friend
who's not native was squishing
grasshoppers for fun
Henry tried to stop him and the friend
said they're just bugs it doesn't matter
but Henry told him they're not just bugs
they're our relatives and you can't kill
them
so that was the summer I had to learn
how to keep grasshoppers for meeting my
garden with garlic spray because every
time I went to use pesticides or
something that would kill them I thought
of Henry and what kind of future we
might have if we actually lived like
that
land back is about radically rethinking
how we relate to the land and other
living beings
so look up who's land you're on some
tribes like the aloni and duwamish have
a way for you to pay a voluntary land
tax on their website as a way to
recognize that you're a guest on their
Homeland way easier than dealing with
the IRS
or maybe you do on land but you need to
live there for now you can set up a
bequest in your will so that your state
goes back to the tribe
I'm not saying that any of this is easy
unsettling is hard work especially in
places where indigenous people were
removed or erased
that absence tends to be papered over
with the myth that colonialism worked
native people disappeared so there's
nothing to worry about
but when I look at my own family's
history
the government that took our land and
outlawed our ceremonies
the boarding schools that took our
language
the epidemic of sexual violence that has
touched nearly every native woman in my
family
all of these concerted efforts to end
the story of us as an ishinabe people
and yet
despite all that we're still here
our survival as indigenous people is a
miracle
and the point of Miracles is that they
Inspire action
I think if we're honest as human beings
we know that this path we're on is both
morally untenable and ecologically
unsustainable
land back is a call to action
to get real that the current system
is only really working for an
increasingly smaller group of folks
but when the people who are benefiting
from this Legacy of stolen land step
forward real change can happen
this isn't just an opportunity to write
a past Injustice
it's the only way to heal the land
itself
and that
means a better future for everyone
thank you
[Applause]